a divided nation produced a split result
both of the Front Runners claiming to be
ahead both becoming aware that this
election is probably heading towards a
second round runoff
the foundation has made its choice in
favor of the second round of the
election
then that is also welcome
we believe that we will finish this
round with over 50 percent of the votes
supporters May cling to that hope that
his rival seems reconciled to a second
election
over the coming 15 days we will fight
for turkey together with our nation to
bring rights laws and Justice to this
country
our people should be certain that we
will absolutely absolutely win and we
will bring democracy to this country
thank you to all of you
there were plenty of people out last
night but nobody with a clear reason to
celebrate it was a victory party without
a victory here's the man who came third
in this poll the Nationalist leader who
attracted millions of votes we meet him
in the small hours
he told me he's now speaking to both
sides about a deal he wants a job in
government in return for his support
we see ourselves as the insurance in the
Turkish government he told me Mr
killisterolo does not have much foreign
policy experience and Mr erdogan is an
individualist now being in would balance
this
this election had started in daylight
with huge crowds at polling stations and
candidates promising Victory it's gone
through the night and back to Daylight
again and a result still seems elusive